[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález regresamos
después de un corto receso por motivos
de la pandemia de kobe 19 pero acá
estamos de vuelta en el debate de france
24 con otro tema para analizar y es
precisamente esa gira por europa del
presidente de eeuu joe biden que sirvió
para buscar consensos y también
acercamientos entre los aliados
occidentales para dejar de lado ese
distanciamiento que había dejado la
política exterior de la anterior
administración en eeuu ahora baiden con
sus aliados busca contrarrestar el peso
que tiene china para así romper
digámoslo con su poderío económico que
avanza rápidamente también buscó frenar
esa agresiva política exterior de rusia
en un encuentro cara a cara con el
presidente ruso vladimir putin a quien
dijo le marcaría sus líneas rojas que
tanto lo pudo hacer el presidente de byd
en que reaccionó en beijing a estos
encuentros que opinamos con y que dicen
también los aliados europeos que se han
mostrado también con algunas opiniones
diferentes a las que tiene washington
al manejo de la relación que deben de
tener con china pues son muchas las
preguntas y muchos puntos para analizar
por supuesto y para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a la doctora yadira
gálvez salvador ella es profesora e
investigadora en el centro de relaciones
internacionales de la universidad
nacional autónoma de méxico la unam ella
se encuentra allí en la capital mexicana
en ciudad de méxico y también está con
nosotros
andrés servín él es doctor en ciencias
políticas y analista internacional
también es presidente del think tank
regional crisis y creo que lo dije bien
él se encuentra en la ciudad de buenos
aires la capital argentina y le recuerdo
que ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar sus preguntas
y sus comentarios en las redes sociales
se la recuerdo estamos en facebook y
también no se encuentran en instagram y
en twitter como france24
s mi cuenta personal arroba sant y luego
la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
pues ya tenemos a los invitados y
tenemos el tema y muchos temas por
delante para analizar comienzo entonces
por yadira en la ciudad de mexico
preguntándole sus impresiones
esta gira el presidente de eeuu joe
biden que comenzó con un encuentro con
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson luego con una reunión del g7
reunión de la otan reunión con putin
reunión con los aliados de la unión
europea agenda completa
agenda completa santiago muy buenas
noches y sin duda con una lógica
estratégica muy clara por parte del
presidente by denny de eeuu regresar y
mantener y fortalecer en realidad los
vínculos transatlánticos con el clásico
socio y aliado de estado 2 que es españa
pero también es un regreso a la otan es
una recomposición de esta alianza que
para el presidente de bailén se antoja
desde una lógica estratégica frente
precisamente a los dos grandes
competidores que ubica a eeuu en este
momento por un lado una china con un
ascenso económico fundamental
importantísimo pero también con una
capacidad tecnológica cada vez más en
ascenso y sin duda rusia y hay que
decirlo no solamente es un tema desde la
perspectiva estadounidense de recuperar
los lazos con los socios europeos sino
también de llevar esta confrontación
tanto con rusia como con china a una
lógica que va a ir en ha identificado
desde la propia campaña que tiene que
ver con
ideología y con lo que él ha señalado
como sustantivo que tiene que ver con
los valores y principios de eeuu y la
búsqueda de un bloque sólido un bloque
fuerte frente a estos competidores en
una también dinámica de amistad
enemistad porque bryant está buscando
también puntos de cooperación y de
inflexión santiago andrés en la ciudad
de buenos aires- sus impresiones sobre
esta gira del presidente vaivén por
europa
bueno yo concuerdo en realidad con mi
colega en el sentido de que la primera
parte de la gira fue para reafirmar y
restaurar los lazos con los socios
transatlánticos de eeuu y de alguna
manera mostrar que eeuu estaba dispuesto
a asumir nuevamente un liderazgo global
y para eso necesitaba requería de la
colaboración de su socio entonces todo
lo que fue la reunión del g7 en
particular y la reunión de la otan
estaban encaminados en esa dirección
pero también estaban encaminados en
presentar una imagen de que los socios
estaban aliados detrás de eeuu
en el encuentro con putin
y aquí hay muchas interpretaciones
digamos hay unas lecturas muy accesibles
en función de qué bueno había esta
atención está enemistad de las
relaciones estaban en su punto más bajo
con rusia pero también hay lecturas con
respecto a por qué este esta decisión
del presidente de byd en de llegar a esa
reunión el computing y conversar con él
cara a cara y yo creo que más allá de
los temas de la agenda que primaron
durante toda la reunión entre ellos el
tema de la estabilización estratégica en
la relación entre ambos países hay
varios puntos a resaltar primero baiden
reconoce de alguna manera que rusia es
una potencia cosa que satisface al
presidente putin y esto es un punto
fundamental para entender lo que viene a
continuación bailén está mandando un
mensaje de que bueno podemos sentarnos a
dialogar y cooperar en una serie de
temas que son relevantes para
las dos partes y bueno en otros temas
tenemos que marcar líneas rojas claras
en el sentido de que bueno cada uno
tiene su posición pero esto implica un
reconocimiento de que es un interlocutor
rusia es un interlocutor válido y el
trasfondo de todo esto es que hay un
mensaje que va mucho más allá y va a la
relación estrecha que han establecido
rusia y china- y bailén lo menciona
varias veces en la conferencia de prensa
que dan a continuación de la reunión en
el sentido de asomar para rusia la
posibilidad de no estar tan
estrechamente relacionado con china no
nos olvidemos que rusia tiene casi el
40% de su comercio es con la unión
europea su vinculación y las inversiones
estadounidenses son vinculación
económica las inversiones
estadounidenses son muy importantes para
la economía rusa y ese también es un
tema que está ahí flotando porque en
relación con las sanciones económicas en
fin este es un poco el panorama cómo se
presenta el proceso de la gira con su
desenlace en la red
con putin ya vamos a profundizar en esos
diferentes temas que usted ha mencionado
andrés quiero preguntarle a yadira si
usted considera que la lectura que ha
hecho la estrategia de la política
internacional del presidente by the end
es correcta y lo digo en el sentido de
porque él conoce muy bien la política de
eeuu a lo largo de todos estos años como
senadora estaba encargado de diferentes
momentos importantes sobre todo con la
relación entre washington y moscú pero
el mundo ha cambiado y el mundo presenta
en este momento unos actores como por
ejemplo china que son diferentes
ya lo decía andrés en esta reunión de
pronto baiden pudo reconocer a rusia
como un igual igual con el que se habla
cara a cara pero a china no es un
escenario muy distinto y tal vez eeuu
sigue pensando que su deber es ser el
país que representa las libertades que
que las van a liderar en todo el mundo
pero hay unos países que están llegando
a tener casi el mismo peso político
comercial y económico que ellos a nivel
internacional está eeuu haciendo una
lectura correcta
el panorama internacional que estamos
viviendo ahora
pues mira santiago vaivén parte como un
gran conocedor que desde los asuntos
exteriores del hecho de que donald trump
marcó un antes y un después de eeuu en
el mundo en el sentido de su posición
frente a sus socios atlánticos y también
de disrupciones respecto a esta relación
va a ir en ha señalado constantemente
que eeuu necesita regresar al mundo y
restablecer sus vínculos multilaterales
con la finalidad de poder competir y
poder mantener su liderazgo y como tú
bien lo acabas de señalar ellos asumen
desde la perspectiva de la
administración baiden quienes sí están
asumiendo una agenda alrededor de los
principios los valores del liderazgo en
un contexto donde ellos lo están leyendo
de compleja relación tanto con china
como con rusia en qué sentido en una
confrontación permanente que vamos a
estar viendo por la dinámica propia que
tanto china como rusia están manteniendo
tenemos una por un lado una visión del
presidente by de dónde está buscando
y generar una lógica de
complementariedad del tipo de
instrumentos que eeuu tiene decir
apuesta por la democracia por la
diplomacia y perdón sin dejar de lado
este tema de la capacidad económica y el
punto aquí es acercarse a rusia pero la
pregunta es que tanto rusia va a
responder a este acercamiento en el
sentido de revertir sus intereses que
tiene sobre occidente y esto es muy
claro putin ha señalado una y otra vez
que rusia además merece un papel
distinto en el contexto internacional y
es claro que conflictos como el de
ucrania o precisamente el poder
energético ruso son factores
fundamentales para entender esta
ecuación y del doctorado santiago en
eeuu se identifica a china como un
competidor estratégico en ascenso y
precisamente en temas como las diversas
defensa la contienda tecnológica y por
supuesto que la ampliación económica de
china no sólo en la zona de las
específicos sino también en américa
latina son asuntos que tendría que
en consideración la administración
andrés de su opinión al respecto
fundamentalmente creo que más que una
reacción frente a occidente lo que putin
busca es consolidar los intereses de
rusia los intereses nacionales tiene una
visión soberanista en eso coincide con
otros actores como china y eso de alguna
manera se ha encaminado en la relación
como se está dando en este momento de
cooperación de diálogo con eeuu para
rusia más que un interés sobre occidente
lo que hay es un interés de preservar su
independencia y su papel de potencia en
el sistema internacional y aquí entra a
tallar otro problema que también a veces
se pierde de vista en el sentido de que
rusia se encuentra inmersa en una
situación en una transición del sistema
internacional en donde pareciera que el
eje ordenador del nuevo orden mundial va
a ser la bipolaridad estratégica entre
china y estados unidos y rusia necesita
ubicarse de una manera que no la
comprometa en ningún tipo de
confrontación
por más que esta confrontación no sea
ideológica entre rusia y china nyse a la
confrontación de carácter armado por lo
menos hasta el momento entonces esto le
ha dado la posibilidad de rusia de
reubicarse de definir claramente dónde
está parada y con respecto al baile no
hay que olvidar que aquí los mensajes no
van dirigidos solamente al exterior por
parte de bailén el hecho de que baile no
haya querido tener una conferencia
conjunta con putin al final del
encuentro
yo creo mi deber responde principalmente
el hecho que vaya de frente a su
audiencia doméstica estadounidense no
quiere aparecer en la misma situación de
trump estrechándose estrechando un
abrazo obteniendo una mayor relación
computing cordial y de amistad como lo
mostraba en su momento el presidente de
trammo y este es un mensaje muy
importante para la audiencia y con esto
cierro por para la audiencia
estadounidense porque fundamentalmente
la prioridad de byte en
y porque hace lo que hace en política
exterior es garantizar el bienestar de
los ciudadanos estadounidenses y mejorar
su situación y eso también se vio
reflejado en esa rueda de prensa en
donde el presidente by the end no
respondió preguntas de ninguno de los
medios rusos que estaban presentes allí
en ginebra- cubriendo esta cumbre entre
los dos mandatarios cosa contraria que
hizo el presidente putin que sí
respondió a algunos medios occidentales
fue muy nombrada esa pregunta que le
hizo el corresponsal de la bbc en moscú
en un perfecto ruso hablándoles sobre la
posición de rusia y putin si se le pidió
a responderle las preguntas incómodas
que le van a hacer los medios
occidentales
les propongo a los dos que sigamos
hablando de rusia antes de entrar al
tema de china y otan que sigamos
analizando este este momento importante
de esta semana y fuerza esa cumbre y es
el papel que entonces puede jugar rusia
en esa negociación o en ese acercamiento
o en esa forma de cómo se pueden empezar
a manejar esas relaciones entre
washington y beijing a través de moscú
en este momento está con algunas
sanciones internacionales y también está
en un momento económico difícil que tal
vez le conviene acercarse un poco más a
eeuu para empezar a reactivar esa
economía sobre todo cuando putin
necesita mostrarles resultados a los a
los ciudadanos rusos de cara a
mantenerse en el poder más de estos 20
años que ya lleva que el papel entonces
podría jugar rusia en esa bisagra entre
washington y beijing andrés
russia claramente yo estaba escuchando
hace un rato a una discusión entre
analistas rusos y ellos plantean con
mucha claridad de que rusia no quiere ni
actuar como mediador ni participar en
esa pelea lo que quiere rusia es
preservar su propio interés nacional
entonces en ese sentido sí le importa
restablecer todo lo que sean los lazos y
vínculos económicos más que nada con
europa que es un socio importante en la
unión europea es un socio
particularmente importante no quiere al
llenar lo avanzado en términos de los
vínculos económicos con china pero yo
creo que también tiene un margen de
desconfianza con respecto a cómo se
relaciona con china porque no le gusta a
los rusos en general no les gusta oír
que china se presenta como el hermano
mayor de la relación y esa actitud de
superioridad genera bastante reticencia
y además ha habido tensiones en las
relaciones a pesar de la cooperación en
la convergencia en el ámbito de asia
central entonces yo creo que rusia
en esta situación de bipolaridad va a
tratar de mantener una posición lo más
autónoma posible yo no digo equidistante
no sabemos cómo va a evolucionar depende
de las oportunidades que se le ofrezcan
y ya vive su opinión sobre este eje
entre beijing y washington a través de
moscú
si no puedo coincidir más que con lo que
ha señalado andrés sobre el papel de
rusia de ellos están buscando putin está
buscando potenciar su papel como el gran
líder que retomo y que además
reconstruyó esta narrativa sobre el
papel de rusia en el mundo y en este
sentido putin va a apostar no va a ser
una bisagra ni tampoco hacer un
intermediario entre la contienda o en
las relaciones entre china y eeuu sino
hacer un actor determinante en la
configuración del sistema internacional
y rusia ha buscado desde hace ya varios
años el tema de la multipolaridad rusia
ha señalado constantemente que se le
tiene que tomar en cuenta como la gran
potencia euroasiática que es juega
muchísimo con su poder energético con la
capacidad que ha tenido putin por
ejemplo para atender temas y vincularse
asuntos tan estratégicos como fue el
caso de siria y para mantener su
presencia frente a los socios europeos
en el caso de ucrania crimea
es decir no se está jugando a la
política de poder
un pragmático de en este momento
acercarse a eeuu con una visión
específica sobre temas que hay que
abordar como es el asunto nuclear como
es el tema por ejemplo de las
dimensiones de la seguridad pero siempre
con esta perspectiva primero de que los
intereses nacionales rusos se tienen que
preservar y se tiene que mantener el
papel de rusia no sólo en eurasia sino
en el mundo
y aprovechando insisto no sólo la
capacidad energética del país sino
también el potencial en términos
militares o sea se asume como una
potencia desde el discurso de meoni debe
de vladimir putin de 2007 hacia acá
claramente identificada con esta
reivindicación de su papel en el mundo
yadira y en que van a quedar puntos
importantes que hubo en esta en esta
reunión y ginebra y es la situación de
ucrania que claramente está entre
washington y moscú y es el punto de
discrepancia entre estos dos países
entre otros tantos porque también está
el caso en avant y también están los
ciberataques pero el punto de ucrania le
preocupa
la unión europea les preocupa que
estalle otra vez un conflicto en la
región del donbass o que nuevamente
rusia a través de sus mecanismos como ya
lo ha demostrado en afasia en osetia y
en crimea se anexe territorios y se vaya
poco a poco consumiendo el territorio de
ucrania y aproxime mucho más su frontera
hacia una frontera de la otan en países
del este de europa como lo voy a usted
si no es un tema menor la gran
preocupación europea es el papel y la
potencialidad de rusia para llevar
adelante una serie de desde ataques
cibernéticos y su posicionamiento frente
a la unión europea hasta el
mantenimiento de estos conflictos que ya
tienen un buen tiempo y que no se han
resuelto y que lo han avanzado a pesar
de las sanciones por un lado y de la
capacidad de de ruso frente a la
capacidad de rusia de mantenerse en este
sentido a mí me parece que para los
europeos el hecho de que de que putin y
en este momento joe biden estén sentados
en una en un contexto o no de esta
lógica de atender algunos problemas
comunes es una noticia que hay que verla
con muchísima digamos que hay que ser
muy prudentes en el análisis porque
porque al final de la historia la unión
europea ha identificado que tienen
necesariamente que desarrollar sus
propias capacidades pero es un deseo que
no se ha consolidado y por otro lado
rusia va a seguir jugando a mantener su
posición en europa y avanzar cuando sea
posible por esta propia narrativa de
putin frente a los otros poderes no está
está a ida y venida entre rusia y los
europeos donde finalmente la unión
europea queda en medio de esta
confrontación pero que también ya se dio
cuenta derivado de la elección y de la
relación control que tienen
necesariamente que desarrollar sus
capacidades frente a rusia en el
contexto además de amenazas híbridas
porque no hay que olvidarlo no solamente
estamos estando todos estatales sino
también de todos los grupos no estatales
que están involucrados en estos
conflictos santiago si el tema de
defensa le preocupa mucho a bruselas
sobre todo porque rusia pues es
completamente autónomo tiene sus fuerzas
armadas sus ejércitos y europa en cierta
forma depende de la otan de pie depende
también de la ayuda que le pueda otorgar
eeuu quiero empezar a tocar el tema de
china que fue el tema destacado de este
encuentro importante la forma como se
abordó él
de vista que tiene eeuu andrés en cuanto
a la posición de china en materia
económica de materia comercial de
ustedes lo estaban contando pero muy
distinta es la perspectiva que tiene en
países como por ejemplo alemania veíamos
a la canciller angela merkel diciendo
que con china pues hay que tener una
relación de balance de equilibrio porque
si bien pueden tener discrepancias en
muchos temas hay que tener una relación
necesaria con china como me gusta y esa
esa alianza que puede tener la unión
europea con eeuu para manejar el tema
china
lo que pasa es que estamos en un mundo
altamente interdependiente desde el
punto de vista económico y hay un
convenio firmado entre la unión europea
china que de alguna manera incrementa el
comercio bilateral y la posibilidad de
inversiones chinas en europa y en ese
contexto la declaración del otan fue fue
fue muy interesante como se planteó la
declaración de la otan porque se planteó
como principal amenaza a rusia y como un
desafío o como un riesgo china pero
parecía que en el primer plano ante la
otan rusia era el gran peligro y no
china pero cuando seguimos con la
evolución de la gira de haydn vemos que
reaparece como la gran amenaza por lo
menos para eeuu y como el gran
competidor fundamentalmente aparece
china lo que pasa que esta bipolaridad
quizás es importante señalar a uno no
tiene las características de la guerra
fría porque insisto no es una
confrontación ideológica básicamente
pasa
por la competencia tecnológica y
comercial entre las dos grandes
potencias y el ascenso vertiginoso si
ustedes quieren de una en relación con
la otra que es la pones justamente en la
situación de disputa estratégica muy
importante ahora europa en esa situación
está colocada inclusive yo diría una
posición de mayor debilidad desde el
punto de vista estratégico que rusia
porque europa en si bien se ha abocado a
resolver sus problemas internos y a
consolidar la unión europea como tal
exceptuando la situación del break sheet
con gran bretaña desde luego en términos
de su política exterior es muy difícil
pensar una europa que funcione de una
manera homogénea con una capacidad de
respuesta colectiva sin que pase por una
serie de debates internos entonces que
la persona que está encargada ahora las
relaciones exteriores de europa josep
borrell si tiene posiciones muy claras
sobre la necesidad de mantener la
autonomía estratégica de europa sobre el
hecho de que el mundo no es bipolar sino
multipolar y en eso si coinciden con los
rusos interesantes esta visión pero en
general estamos hablando de que el lg
ordenador pareciera del sistema
internacional que está emergiendo es la
disputa estratégica entre chile eeuu y
los otros actores ven cómo se ubican
frente a esto de tal manera de no ser
perjudicados y poder mantener la defensa
de sus intereses nacionales en algunos
casos por una visión más soberanista con
el caso de rusia en otros casos con
revisión ya las demás vinculadas a un
modelo de bienestar social como en el
caso de europa no además que la unión
europea no ha podido definir una
política exterior completamente concreta
el 27 políticas exteriores que en
algunos momentos salen a relucir todas
en otros momentos dejan que bruselas sea
la que tome el liderazgo pero pero en
escenarios como este se hace compleja
tomar una posición como usted ya lo dice
y ahí es cuando washington y beijing
toman posiciones un poco más afianzadas
y la unión europea queda
en la mitad yadira hay que temerle a
china hay que temerle al ascenso chino
hay que temerle a ese ascenso militar
que está teniendo china a esa posición
que está tomando estratégica a nivel
mundial y sobre toda esa política
exterior de aproximación a los países
menos desarrollados en términos
económicos y de infraestructura y hacer
unas alianzas de construcción de
infraestructura a cambio de recursos que
hay donde tal vez eeuu está dejando
terreno que china está aprovechando
santiago más que temerle creo que hay
que darle un seguimiento puntual y
comprender la lógica que está
desplegando china en materia de política
exterior
primero porque justo los chinos han
asumido una narrativa sobre el respeto
irrestricto de las cuestiones
relacionadas con soberanía tipos de
gobiernos es decir no se meten en esas
cuestiones que por ejemplo eeuu y
respecto a derechos humanos o al tipo de
régimen político en algunos espacios es
decir china mantiene esta narrativa
sobre su política exterior vinculada al
principio de no intervención buscando
sus intereses y efectivamente
expandiéndose alrededor del mundo con
iniciativas tan importantes como es el
tema de la ruta de la seda oa través de
mecanismos de cooperación hay que seguir
muy de cerca el despegue militar que ha
tenido el país porque el propio eeuu ha
advertido que si bien todavía no podemos
hablar de unas capacidades equiparable
como las que tiene eeuu si ha
evolucionado de una manera vertiginosa
en los últimos años y particularmente
también el desarrollo de las capacidades
tecnológicas que tiene china es decir es
una potencia en ascenso dispuesta a
mantener este ritmo de crecimiento
económico y mantener sus intereses
estratégicos en el mundo de una forma
distinta el ejercicio del liderazgo y
del poder chino en el mundo es muy
distinto que lo que hemos visto en
términos justo narrativos e ideológicos
de eeuu pensemos por ejemplo en el caso
de mi alma para golpe de estado china
mantiene sus intereses su dinámica su
relación con la junta militar mientras
que estados unidos y los europeos
señalan claramente que hay implicaciones
en materia de humanos y en este sentido
a mí me parece que bailén si está
llevando el tema a una narrativa de
diferencias ideológicas y de principios
y valores entre uno y otro país que hay
que tener
liberación porque precisamente el gran
enemigo o el gran en realidad no enemigo
pero sí competidor estratégico de eeuu
en este siglo es precisamente china sin
descartar descartar el papel de rusia en
esta ecuación en un mundo multipolar
donde la hegemonía militar
estadounidense y la lógica de su
presencia en el mundo si se va en riesgo
santiago está en riesgo es una la
política exterior china es una política
tal vez pensando un poco más a largo
plazo dando unas condiciones muy
diferentes a las que daba eeuu a las que
por ejemplo desde aquí desde américa
latina hemos estado más acostumbrados y
vemos que china llega con una
aproximación muy distinta tal vez
innovadora y eso ha cautivado algunos
países sobre todo en áfrica que ya vemos
la presencia importantísima que tiene
china en el desarrollo de las
infraestructuras en el continente
africano ya para llegar al último bloque
de este programa quería preguntarle a
los dos
esta gira por europa el presidente joe
biden fue prácticamente su debut en la
comunidad internacional había mucha
presión de por medio a eeuu por este
regreso del america bac que viene en el
escenario internacional el debut de
bailén ante sus socios europeos y bueno
ya lo decíamos restablecer esa conexión
con moscú y tener una posición con china
cómo evalúan ustedes estas alianzas como
evalúan el desempeño de bailén en el
establecimiento de estas políticas de
bueno de la política exterior de eeuu de
este nuevo gobierno ya dirá para el
cierre
pues sin duda en la idea precisamente
del regreso al mundo de bailén descansa
un mayor ejercicio del poder diplomático
y el poder económico de eeuu buscando
generar mayor confianza me parece sin
duda que ese es el punto de partida el
restablecimiento de la confianza y la
búsqueda también de la estabilidad en el
sentido de los intereses vitales de eeuu
y byron va a mantener esta narrativa
donde también como lo señaló andrés hace
un momento le está hablando al público
interno a sus votantes respecto primero
al papel de eeuu en el mundo y
particularmente a la visión que tiene
sobre insisto la promoción de democracia
de derechos humanos entonces me parece
que es un punto de partida pero también
no podemos dejar de pensar en el
pragmatismo propio de eeuu y que están
perfilando también el combate yadira
rápidamente de 1 a 10 cuanto lo califica
85 85 andre su opinión como evalúa usted
entonces la esta primera incursión del
presidente byte en en la escena
internacional
bueno totalmente coherente con el
planteamiento inicial de él de primero
poner la casa en orden y reforzar el
ordenamiento de la casa con una política
exterior y basada en la diplomacia mucho
más eficiente y mucho más coherente que
la de la administración previa yo creo
que en ese sentido ha avanzado muy bien
es un hombre con mucha experiencia no
solamente en lo político en lo interno
sino también experiencia internacional
conoce con quién está hablando fue muy
importante tener por primera vez desde
el 2011 si no me equivoco una
interlocución de nuevo computing él
estaba en otra posición ahora es de
igual a igual y yo creo que en ese
sentido está construyendo en función de
los intereses de eeuu
y en función de la visión que él tiene
de cómo debería estar eeuu en el mundo
está construyendo correctamente
el camino hacia los objetivos que se
propone durante su presidencia aquí hay
una salvedad que yo creo que es muy
importante que hay que tener en cuenta
va a ser presidente por tres años y
medio más después no sabemos y eso es
también lo que se pregunta muchos de sus
aliados entonces dependiendo de la
performance de cómo se desenvuelve en
estos años y que el legado deja así se
da la situación de eeuu dentro de cuatro
años con una polarización política
interna tan fuerte como la que se está
dando en este momento si andrés de 1 a
10 cuánto le califica todo diría entre 7
y 8 me queda un minuto para el cierre
que creen ustedes que faltó en esta gira
qué temas quedaron por fuera que eran
importantes andrés rápidamente 20
segundos hay un tema que tienen que
tratar en conjunto que si asomaron en la
agenda es el tema del cambio climático y
del arte
tanto bailén como putin lo señalaron en
sus conferencias de prensa pero eso es
un tema del futuro porque además ahí
claramente se muestra que hay la
posibilidad de una cooperación porque
los dos países son miembros del consejo
ártico y también hay una amenaza muy
empleada por parte de china que no lo es
sí ya dirá que es de 520 segundos
coincidió con andrés cambio climático
seguridad energética y resiliencia
también frente a los desastres
ambientales que se ve bueno pues añadir
a gálvez en ciudad de méxico entre
servín y la ciudad de buenos aires en
argentina les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros en este debate de france 24
ustedes también les recuerdo que pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
de france 24 y por supuesto pueden ver
este y otros episodios del debate en
france 24 punto com sigan con nuestra
programación
[Música]